foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
maximizing metastasis insights with a
novel integrated workflow for CTC
enrichment and enumeration
I'm Christy Jewel of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by bio rad Laboratories
to learn more please visit biograd.com
forward slash sell select
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical
questions here as well if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I would now like to welcome our speaker
Dr Adam Corner single cell Market
development manager digital biology
biograd Laboratories
welcome Adam you may now begin your
presentation
thank you Christy
what I will do is give you a brief
overview of liquid biopsies and ctcs to
give you a little bit of context
and then I'll move on to explain how the
Genesis system the cell isolation system
works functions together with the novel
slide technology we have called cell
select
once we have an understanding of the
system I'll move into a range of
applications and workflows to illustrate
how we and our customer base are
utilizing this system
the liquid biopsies and ctcs the concept
of liquid biopsies has been around for
over a decade now and typically it's put
in the context of blood there are other
liquid biopsies available but often in
the context of blood so if we focus on
that for the start there are two major
sections within blood as a liquid biopsy
the plasma fracture and the cellular
fracture and there are a range of
molecule types and cell types available
within those the most common
investigated investigated area would be
CT DNA within the plasma and and ctcs
and CTC clusters within the cellular
fracture we're going to talk about
primarily enriching and enumerating ctcs
from the cellular fraction
the reason ctc's our value is that they
are a fantastic representation of the
heterogeneity of a primary tumor
the released from the primary tumor and
Seed metastases around the body by
entering the blood system or the lymph
system and for micro metastases around
the body which over time potentially
grow into overt metastases
because they're found within blood
they're amenable to non-invasive liquid
biopsies by a simple blood draw and
actually although we're focusing on ctcs
today they can be seen as complementary
to the information contained within
ctdna2
there's a lot of Publications on the
range of CTC counts and we can see from
the graph that's on the screen at the
moment that different cancer types have
classically different
amounts of ctcs found within a standard
blood sample so breast cancer
CTC numbers are at one extreme with very
high numbers ranging from tens to
hundreds if not thousands of ctcs in a
standard blood draw across to pancreatic
cancer for example which may only have
small individual numbers of ctcs within
a seven and a half mil blood draw but
it's very variable so it's not uncommon
to get samples that do span that whole
range
for that reason it's quite important to
be able to capture those ctcs using
um
technology like the Genesis platform
where we can enrich the ctcs away from
the large numbers of residual white
blood cells and red blood cells and from
a sample perspective although I've
talked about blood as as the primary
liquid biopsy there are other liquid
biopsy capabilities that are out there
depending on the cancer that you're
investigating and it may well make sense
to investigate cerebral spinal fluid for
glioma medulloblastoma tumors in the
brain or for example looking at urine as
a liquid biopsy and the the CTC content
within within urine if you're focusing
on bladder renal or prostate cancers
there are several Legacy platforms out
there for enriching for ctcs but they
all come with certain limitations and
they do vary quite a lot it may well be
that the platforms out there are
reducing their sensitivity so when you
have very low numbers of ctcs which is
quite a common occurrence you just don't
see them or you have low capture
efficiency where at the other end you
have lots of ctc's but still only
capture a few of them because the vast
majority are not captured using the
technology that you're working with it
may be a processing rate or throughput
issue
um
liquid biopsy samples are relatively
labile it's important to capture the
ctc's relatively quickly depending on
the different blood tubes that are used
so it's quite important to have a sample
processing and and throughput capability
within your platform that allows for
those samples to be utilized and we'll
see that the Genesis platform has a
pretty good
um processing rate and throughput rate
or it may well just be that you have an
incomplete system typically
investigators are interested in looking
at enriching ctcs for Downstream
applications but also in parallel
enumerating those ctcs using antibody
immuno labeling if you can't do both
you're actually quite Limited in what
you can achieve with a clinical sample
so let me spend a little bit of time now
walking you through the Genesis cell
isolation system and the associated cell
select slide technology
foreign
the limitations that I've just described
is a high capture efficiency system
with increased sensitivity down to
really quite small single integer
numbers of ctcs in a sample
it's very easy as a workflow very walk
away as a workflow but also highly
customizable and flexible and the
throughput capabilities I'll go through
later on allow you to look at multiple
samples a day up to 10 samples for an
enrichment protocol a day
we also have the two primary
applications I've mentioned already
enrichment and enumeration as standard
certified workflows but we have a whole
range of flexibility Downstream of that
depending on what you want to do with
enriched ctcs that you've previously
captured
so the Genesis system is the instrument
and then underneath that contained
within the workflow are the cell select
slides and you can see a graphical
representation on the screen which if we
blow up we can see contains
microfluidic capabilities and micro
pores the micro pores are designed to
capture ctcs that have a slightly larger
size than standard white and red blood
cells and the red blood cells and white
blood cells would pass through those
micro
micropause like a sieve
expanding that view a little bit further
we can see that we have a sample we have
a slide a cell select slide contained
within an integrated manifold part of
the system that allows the sample to be
applied on the left hand side and then
pulled through with a gentle vacuum to
the right hand side cells are captured
in the bottom image you can see the the
ctc's represented in blue are captured
within the wells the red blood cells and
the white blood cells pass through
the microfluidic capability is based
around over 56 000 micro chambers that
allows us to capture as many ctcs as we
think but give a very even flow rate
through those micro well so the
sufficient Continuous Flow that we don't
cause back pressure on the on the cells
that are captured
the capture efficiency is around 80
percent of ctcs and CTC clusters and
I'll illustrate some examples of that in
later slides and cells that are captured
can either be taken down the enumeration
workflow where they're where they main
resident within the wells and then are
immune-labeled with antibodies on the
slide or they can be flushed off the
microfluidics slide and taken down into
subsequent molecular or cellular biology
workflows and again I'll expand on that
later on
the poor size has been designed to
incorporate the range of ctcs that we
would expect across the vast majority of
solid tumors so you can see individual
CTC sizes represented pictorial on the
right hand side of this graph
collectively giving you a Broadband on
the left hand side
platelets and red blood cells will flush
straight through on the whole and the
majority of white blood cells although
potentially slightly larger than the
pore size will also pass through the
pores because of their deformability
their inherent deformability as a cell
within the blood system
so let me show you a Greek video of a
flyover of the system we can see in in
this image at the moment we can see we
have two channels that's an integrated
part of the workflow I'm just going to
flick through to the actual video and
I'll press play and then I'll walk you
through what we see
so now as we fly down over the system
you can see the two waste jars at the
front in front of the two channels we
pan around and the slide the cell select
slide is actually encased inside a
manifold and a slide holder which holds
it rigid within the microfluid it's
allowing us to pull the vacuum and the
sample across we can see the red blood
cells and the white blood cells flowing
down the channels and ultimately being
allowed to flow through the micropores
the larger cells in blue the ctc's enter
the wells but don't flow through and
that's the fundamental process that
allows us to remove the red blood cells
and the white blood cells and enrich for
the ctcs
so for for an enrichment capability we
have two primary applications we have
cell select slide enrichment and we have
cell select slide enumeration for the
enrichment workflow we capture and we
cover over 80 percent of ctc's from
liquid biopsies
with the associated removal of over 99
of red blood cells and white blood cells
that are that pass through the
micropores and into the waste Channel
because the enrichment workflow is
approximately one hour with very gentle
pressure um
to pull through the majority of the
sample and maintain the ctcs within the
wells we have a very high viability of
recovered cells I'll talk about blood
tubes later on but we would typically
recommend using an EDTA tube with no
fixative a very gentle pressure in the
enrichment protocol and then the cells
are flushed back out into a collection
um consumable that allows you to take
those cells into a range of Downstream
capabilities the viability is maintained
because we don't subject those cells to
very high or very rigorous physical
damage during the collection process
the numeration protocol on the other
hand the recommendation would be to use
a stretch tube to provide initial
fixation to some extent but then those
cells go into the side slow side the
cell select slide to allow for capture
of those cells within the the wells
at this point we then do a series of
antibody immunolabling steps by pushing
reagents across the wells across the
antibodies and out to the waste jar in
either a direct or indirect immune
labeling capability so it takes slightly
longer to do it in in an enumeration
protocol and an enrichment protocol but
at the end of that hands-off protocol
your slide is ready to go with the cells
captured fixed and stained with the
antibodies of your choice such that you
can take that slide onto an automated
microscope and downstream into the image
viewer software for result reporting
I'll now show you a few examples of
recent images that we've captured just
to illustrate what we expect to see so
on screen at the moment we have a very
typical
epithelial CTC capture data set
we have four Images captured
simultaneously on the system that this
was performed on so we did an
enumeration protocol cells were captured
in the microwells that you can see in
the right field view on the left hand
side and then they were stained with
dappy for nuclear staining stained with
gfp for pancit keratin staining to
indicate epithelial ctcs and then any
residual white blood cells were
subsequently stained with cd45 to give a
clear differentiation between ctcs and
white blood cells this then allows us to
differentiate between Wells or cells
that contain sorry cells or Wells that
contain cells between ctcs staining with
dappy-positive and cytic keratin
positive and cd45 negative and white
blood cells which would still stand with
dappy but would be positive for cd45 and
pancit keratin
on the next slide what you'll see is a
very similar set of imagery
we only have ctc's in this example but
actually they're clusters of ctcs so a
common asked question is can we capture
clusters yes the Clusters may not sit
entirely within the well because of
their Collective size but they'll be
held against a well due to the flow
pressures that we utilize and then the
staining occurs just as normal so you
can see the Clusters represented as a
multiple nuclei with the dappy stain
multiple cells with the Panasonic
keratin stain and then again there's no
cd45 staining indicating that their CTC
clusters are not white blood cells
using this system to interrogate
sensitivities and and linearity for
example we have some data on the screen
now that shows the left-hand plot plot a
I'm going to talk about a ANC primarily
they're the ones I want to focus on
today
um show a very nice linear graph showing
that we can capture spiked in ctcs
ranging from the range approximately 10
or 11 cdcs into a blood sample all the
way up to a thousand ctcs we've gone
higher but it's generally the lower end
of sensitivity that people are
interested in because that's really what
you get in clinical samples to find 10
000 ctcs is not realistic to find 10
ctc's is the real question and we have
good linearity across that range
on section c on on plot C what we're
looking at there are different volumes
of blood being interrogated with spiked
in samples
um illustrating that we can work with
our standard formul because typically
there's a requirement to put as much
blood through as possible to increase
sensitivity of capture but actually the
efficiency of capture doesn't change
even if you only have a very small
volume of blood to enrich or enumerate
I mentioned the tubes that we recommend
and we'll probably come back to this in
the questions it's one of the more
common questions that we get typically
we would recommend for enrichment to use
an EDTA tube it's a much gentler
anticoagulant process doesn't fix the
cells so that you can take them
Downstream in a viable state
we would typically recommend stretch
tubes if you're doing enumeration
because there's a fixation step involved
it doesn't matter that you've used
stretch tubes to preserve the the blood
going forward and prevent coagulation
we've also been testing recently
different tubes as we get requests for
cell safe cell rescue or package tubes
and generally what we find is the
ability to enrich or enumerate using any
of these tubes doesn't really differ
which is good it gives you a lot of
flexibility
similarly looking at different cancer
cell types we've tested recently breast
melanoma prostate pancreas colon and
Leukemia the majority of those showed
efficiency of capture of over 80 and
this is just in contrived spiking
experiments we have Publications and
customers using lots of other types of
of
cancer cells cancer ctcs that are just
as effective as well
um the colon value is a little low
that will be repeated we suspect that
was just an anomaly and should be 80
efficiency which we can validate the
leukemia cells because of their inherent
deformability as white blood cells it
was no surprise that the capture
efficiency was much lower but it again
it's an interesting result
I've mentioned several times how
standardized the protocols are we
provide enrichment protocols and
enumeration protocols and it's very
hands-off you set it up you walk away
and depending on which protocol it's
either an hour or two hours when the
results are ready to to take Downstream
um but we also have a huge amount of
flexibility I'll talk about antibody
flexibility later on but in the context
of what's on the screen at the moment we
provide a protocol Builder and that
protocol Builder allows you to take the
three certified protocols that we
provide enrichment and then enumeration
with either indirect or direct staining
and customize those protocols so if you
have cells that require a more gentle or
more aggressive vacuum or you want to
change the reagents that you're
dispensing into change from dappy to
hurt or to change the number of
antibodies that you're using with
multiple antiquotes of different
antibodies because your imagery is more
complex absolutely that's feasible we
can provide the protocol border for you
to do that and if you establish a
protocol for a novel application you can
transfer that to colleagues and
collaborators quite easily
so what I'd like to do now is walk you
through a range of customer Publications
that hint on how our customer base is
using the Genesis platform and the cell
select slide technology
to look at driving personalized medicine
for staging and monitoring of localized
cancer through to metastasis for the
discovery and validation of individual
biomarkers or potentially through the
the propagation of cells for the
identity identification of resistance
mechanisms
we have a range of Publications in this
presentation that look at custom
staining for pdl1 custom staining for
breast cancer subtypes comparison to the
cell search platform to some extent
regarded as the gold standard although
it is epitope pull down based rather
than size based as is the Genesis
platform taking enriched cells down into
a single cell rna-seq analysis or qpcr
analysis
um and then also how potentially
enumeration protocols could be utilized
in a clinical setting for one of our
external research customers rather than
Within bioad
so coming back to that linearity
insensitivity I mentioned on the
previous slide where we've been pushing
the sensitivities down to 10 cells per
spiking experiment this publication from
a couple of years ago actually did
better than that it pushed it all the
way down to five cells per spiking tube
working with non-small cell lung cancer
ctcs illustrating great capture
efficiency with high reproducibility and
then linearity from 5 to 50 cells
added to that which in itself is a
fantastic result
um they also used a customized antibody
staining protocol by incorporating an
antibody for pdl1 into their protocol on
top of cd45 for example just to
illustrate the flexibility of antibody
staining
taking that one step further
although ironically it was before the
previous publication we are here it's
our Illustrated that actually with the
right combination of antibodies you can
not only differentiate epithelial
ctcs from breast cancer samples
you can differentiate epithelial ctcs
from mesenchymal ctcs but you can then
also subclassify different epithelial
cells uh epithelium ctcs depending on
whether they express estrogen receptor
or her2 so if we just walk through what
we have on the screen at the moment we
have the bright field combined imagery
of cells captured in the microwells and
then stained with a range of different
antibodies
the two epithelial cell types mcf7 and
skbr3 are stained with pancit keratin
um and pi3k to indicate epithelial
subtypes but at the same time you can
see in the second and third rows one is
positive for her2 and one is positive
for estrogen receptor so we can identify
them as epithelial but actually they
have different cell surface receptors
being present
then to differentiate the epithelial
cells from mesenchymal cells the MDA
mv231 cells that were captured
did not stain with pi3k but did stain
with fermenting one of the sample
markers that can be used to classify
mesenchymal cells so a really nice
experiment incorporating multiple custom
antibodies to completely segregate three
different cell types although they're
all breast cancer cells
if we compare the data on the screen at
the moment that's that took 18
um prostate cancer samples clinical
samples and subjected them to
enumeration using the cell search system
and then similarly the cell select
slides on the Genesis system we can see
that there's a clear benefit to using
the cell select approach because it's
size based it's unbiased it clearly in
the blue bars pulls out more positive
ctcs per Sample When the cell search
system pulls out cells but actually
several of the samples were negative on
the cell search platform and clearly
positive on the Genesis platform with
salesflex light technology sales were
confirmed to be prostate cancer
positive by use of a PSA antibody so we
have high levels of efficiency above and
beyond what you would expect with the
cell search platform simply by using the
Genesis platform with its unbiased size
selection
sticking with
metastatic breast cancer in this
publication from horimoto hotel they
were similarly interested in
understanding what impact the unbiased
size selection had in being able to
determine progression-free survival
after treatment with every bulin I mean
boolean's a drug known or expected to
impact on epithelial to misenchymal
Transitions so it's quite important to
understand the subpopulations of the
total CTC population that are
mesenchymal or epithelial and the pla
the Genesis platform allows that if we
look at the progression increase
survival plot on the left hand side for
total ctcs we can clearly see a benefit
to low CTC counts
um
when we look at total ctcs however if
you segregate out using antibody
staining epithelial cells from
mesenchymal cells it's only the
mesenchymal fraction that gives a
similar result working with purely
epithelial cells you would you would
struggle to differentiate high and low
CTC counts having an impact on
progression-free Survival so Legacy
systems that only detect epithelial ctcs
are not as effective at monitoring drug
treatment efficacy
and that heterogeneous heterogeneity of
CTC populations is a theme that comes
back again and again depending on how
you're doing it whether it's with
antibodies or in the in the case on
screen at the moment whether it's
through Downstream molecular biology
analysis of that population so in this
paper by Chang at how the ctc's that
were captured across a range of
um metastatic breast cancer patients
were subjected to single cell rna-seq in
this case there are approximately 80
cells that were captured enriched and
they were subjected to single cell
rna-seq and the two plots that we have
on the screen we have a t sneak plot on
the left and we have a heat map for
different Gene
Gene motifs on the right and both of
them clearly differentiate the EMT like
ctcs on the T sneeze spot the red plots
from the Met like cdc's the blue spots
so there's clearly two clusters there
and the the heat map on the right hand
side differentiates similar
subpopulations into met or EMT but also
actually identify as a third
subpopulation of cancer stem cells so
again that heterogeneity can be analyzed
Downstream after viable cell enrichment
on the Genesis platform but it also
illustrates that you are capturing
multiple subpopulations just not the
epithelial population that Legacy
systems would capture
identification of biomarks is quite an
important aspect of Investigations into
ctc's now obviously sequencing as a
protocol can be quite challenging for
biomarker monitoring it's a big
expensive protocol and single cell
sequencing is particularly challenging
so it's not uncommon for individual
biomarkers identified through an NGS
approach either single cell or book or
no sequencing to then be
analyzed individually and the the data
on the screen at the moment focuses very
much on the individual transcript arv7
which is indicated in
um pathogenicity of castration resistant
prostate cancer but it's not a perfect
biomarker in that there's quite a high
false positivity seen in healthy
individuals tested by qpcr for arb7
so the nakasato hotel group tried to
clarify exactly where that false
positivity was coming from by subjecting
clinical samples from concentration
resistant prostate cancer patients to
enrichment on the Genesis platform and
what they found was that if they
compared
um castration resistant prostate cancer
samples to normal samples enrichment of
the ctcs allowed them to get a clear
positive signal on the ctcs well without
a false positive signal from the
residual white blood cells whereas with
wild type samples normal samples there
was no positivity in the background was
low as well so it it allowed for a much
cleaner individual biomarker positivity
after enrichment by the Genesis system
with self-select slides
so hopefully that's given you a
relatively broad understanding of of the
flexibility of the system added on top
of the the rigidity that we have around
standardized workflows and easy
workflows that are hands off and walk
away
just to reiterate the workflows again to
get it very clear in your head we have
two primary applications we have the
enrichment workflow very quick very
simple allows you to capture cells at a
high efficiency level with the
elimination of 99.9 of red blood cells
and white blood cells allowing you to
take those cells into a range of
Downstream applications bioads very well
positioned to allow you to build
comprehensive workflows so if you want
to capture cells
and then feed them into a digital PCR
qpcr or sequencing workflow those cells
are perfectly renewable to that if you
want to take them into a proteomic or or
cellular
um
workflow again those cells being highly
viable relatively gently and Rich can be
fed into the flow cytometry workflow a
mass cytometry workflow or even
potentially in vitro or in Vivo
expansion
and
that gives a perfect combination of CTC
capture CTC enrichment and then
Downstream molecular and cellular
analysis
similarly the enumeration workflow as a
standard workflow is very hands-off very
standardized very easy to work with
requires very little manual input other
than antibody selection and again taking
your sample isolating the cells
capturing them within the microwells and
then immunolabling with different
antibody combinations allows you a level
of flexibility as we've seen in some of
the Publications around fermenting
staining for mesenchymal cells for
example differentiating different breast
cancer cell types using a her2 antibody
compared to an estrogen receptor
antibody
so we have not only standard immuno
labeling in in an enumeration workflow
we can do that with either direct
labeling or indirect labeling based on
your preferences and sensitivity
requirements
once the cells have been captured in an
enumeration workflow and then labeled
through an immunolabling protocol after
washing antibodies onto the slides and
washing them back off removing any
non-bound antibodies the slides as a
standard slide size can be imaged on the
vast majority of Imaging systems in the
market today
those images collected on an automated
Imaging system can then be fed into the
recently released rare cell analysis
software this is a recent addition over
our Legacy image viewer software which
was locked into one particular Imaging
system
this is a fantastic step forward it
allows us to be compatible with many
Imaging systems and many file formats
and it allows you to increase up to six
different fluorescent channels from the
standard four giving you much more
interactive graphical representation so
we can see on the screen at the moment
we have an XY scatter plot of two
different die channels allowing you to
clearly differentiate one clustering
gray compared to one cluster in blue
possibly differentiating between those
that are high stained and low stained
with a different antibody
channel selection is governed by what
you're working with if you have four or
five or six channels as standard on your
imagery you can say which dies and which
channels you're working with and that
that sets the pretext for how you
interpret your data
you then get graphical representations
of your data your collected cells based
on those diet channels and the numerical
values that you add in you plot them
initially and then determine what the
minimum and maximum is so for example if
you're trying to eliminate the presence
of white blood cells you would put a
very low maximum for the cd45 channel
and that would eliminate them from the
XY scatterplots
you can create multiple graphs to
represent different subpopulations
depending on the different combinations
of antibodies that you're incorporating
into your workflow
once you've set the parameters and
determined your final population you
then get to look at those cells one by
one and you get a table of cells on the
left hand side with the values that
you've determined and then a series of
individual images giving you in this
case we can see dappy and blue gfp and
green not present sci-fi very low level
red blood cell and then the different
bright field images and the con a
combined image at the bottom and
ultimately a position on the slide if
you want to go back and review that cell
at a much higher resolution it's at this
point you then get to make a decision is
it a CTC or is it an artifact you can
turn them on or off the purpose being
that once you've sub selected those that
you regard as ctcs
you build a report within that report
capability you can then Define which
channel is used and the numbers used
against that channel to build the report
and then you can add peripheral
information like logos and file names
and file locations as you would in any
file that you're saving ultimately
allowing you to generate a fixed PDF
report of all of the cells that you've
enumerated and regard as correct ctcs
for Downstream archiving storing or for
distribution to individual groups
so in summary what we have is the
Genesis cell isolation system in the
cell select slide technology that allow
you to capture more and recover more and
ultimately accomplish more in your CTC
experiments
we have a capture mechanism which is
both structured and easy to use and
flexible with two core applications of
onslide enumeration or onslide
enrichment with a very high capture
efficiency over 80 with minimal
preprocessing required very little
Hands-On time with optimized protocols
but also the flexibility to Define use
and Define protocols and antibody
requirements
this is the last slide thank you very
much for your attention what we'll do
now is transition across to a q a
session
hosted by Christy
thank you
and thank you Adam for your informative
presentation
yes it is now time for us to start our
live q a portion of the webinar and to
our audience if you have any questions
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
Adam we've have quite a few questions
that have already come in so I'm just
going to start here and um let's go with
this first question what is the maximum
volume of blood as well as the number of
cells that can be run through the cell
select slide
great thank you so so the maximum volume
at this point in time is four mil so you
would take your standard terminal tube
take out formula Bloods dilute that one
to one with PBS and then that would be
applied to an individual cell select
slide so that's that's a maximum I did
show some data for smaller volumes
because we get questions about smaller
volumes whether you've had a poor blood
draw or whether you're potentially
looking at using animal models that
don't produce 10 mil or four mil that
you would apply of blood
the second part of that question is a
little bit more difficult to answer in
the we don't have a maximum number of
cells that you can run through the cell
select slide but we do have a maximum
number of micro Wells so
if you have fifty six thousand four
hundred micro Wells within the
microfluidic system if you fill them all
up with a CTC then you're going to clog
the system so fortunately most samples
do not have 56 000 large cells in them
that require capture so typically
formula blood will flow through
perfectly fine with the tens hundreds or
low thousands of ctc's that you might
have
now Adam this questions come in a few
times how many samples can be run in a
typical eight hour work day
yeah again good question
um we'll start with the the short
approach called the enrichment protocol
takes about an hour and we have two
channels so you could run two samples at
a time I'm being realistic you could
mathematically say oh you know 16
samples but I think realistically you're
probably looking at approximately 12
samples a day with downtime between each
of individual one to swap out
plasticware Etc
the enumeration protocols longer because
you have to capture and wash the cells
and then you have to apply one or two
rounds of antibodies as well as a series
of washes between to ensure low
background noise so we'll probably
realistically look at realistically
looking at four to six samples a day in
an eight hour working day for
enumeration
thank you Adam now speaking of the
enumeration protocols what fluorescent
images or microscopes can be used for
the enumeration protocol
um fortunately at this point any we had
a legacy relationship
um recommending the Agilent biotech
Lionheart and that was partially because
our Legacy software for Downstream
analysis the image analysis software was
based on the files that that system
generated but with the new version of
software that we have now the rare cell
analysis software
um we can take a large range of
different image formats and files from
different systems so we're open to most
of the major image analysis systems that
are on the market at the moment
Adam is there an
ant bio bio-red recommends for
enumeration
um
we have a panel that we can recommend as
a starting point that's typically what
people are looking for how do I start
antibodies will take you know some
optimization to get the concentrations
right or whether they're specific for
the markers those people are interested
in we would typically start with
um pan cytic keratin dappy and cd45 that
allows you to determine epithelial cells
nucleated cells and then include or
exclude white blood cells but typically
beyond that you could include momentum
as we've seen for mesenchymal cells you
could include specific markers like her2
or the estrogen receptor to
differentiate different breast cancer
cell lines so it's open but we that was
that's where we would start with
Panasonic keratin dappy and cd45
thank you Adam
collected a blood sample how soon does
it need to be used with a cell select
um so depending on
which workflow you're doing
whether it's enumeration or enrichment
that kind of determines which tube type
you would use so if we're working with
um enrichment we want typically viable
cells we wouldn't we would not use
stretch we would use EDTA
that then gives you a maximum time for
cells within an EDTA tube at 24 hours
although I would always recommend sunu
is better with edt8 and relatively mild
anticoagulant your cells aren't
particularly well preserved you need to
use them as quickly as you can
or enumeration because we fix the cells
to to some extent not a hard fixation
but it is fixation you can get away with
using stretch tubes the benefit to that
is the stretch tubes have a much better
stability so you can use samples from a
stretch tube up to 96 hours
what I would suggest is or what I would
recommend is actually whichever type of
tube you're using it's vitally important
that you follow the protocols for mixing
the anticoagulant and preservative in
the tubes thoroughly and following the
guidelines any level of coagulation
clotting even micro clots can have a
dramatic impact on the microfluidic
systems
Adam what types of cells other than ctcs
can the Genesis recover
so because we use an unbiased size
selection you can effectively capture in
theory any cell type within the range
greater than eight microns up to 30
microns to be captured in the microwells
and as we've seen with larger cells
potentially or clusters of cells they
can also be captured because they would
reside almost like a plug on the
microwave even if they don't fully fit
inside the microwel so basically
anything within the size range that the
microfluidics in the cell select system
will accept
thank you now Adam we have time for a
few more questions but I do want to
remind our audience that any questions
that we don't have time to answer today
and any questions submitted during that
during our on demand period they will be
addressed by you via the contact
information
that our registrants have provided so
let's take a few more questions
um this next question great presentation
thank you I'm interested in doing
combined CT DNA and CTC analysis from
blood samples does the Genesis have a
workflow protocol that supports this
we have a recommended workflow we don't
have a written workflow at this point in
time but but we are
pretty confident based on other
Publications that you could take a
sample
you could spin the plasma you spin the
cells down and remove the plasma for
ctce extraction take that plasma out of
the tube for CTC extraction and then
resuspend the cells in PBS of an
equivalent volume or potentially twice
the volume because we do that anyway as
part of the one-to-one dilution and then
process that sample as normal and
we would expect the ctcs to be captured
and the CT DNA to be available from the
plasma for subsequent nucleic acid
extraction
thank you Adam and we'll wrap with this
final question what criteria are used
for calling cells as ctcs
So based on the imagery that we capture
it's a it's a range of aspects centered
around the size of this the cell the
circularity or aspect ratio of the cell
and the different differential antibody
staining so for a classic epithelial
cell we would expect it to be punxitos
keratin positive dappy positive and cd45
negative and then we would set
parameters around the size of that
staining depending on which channel you
determine you want to focus on and then
that would exclude or include anything
bigger or smaller than the parameters
and associated with the right
combination of dies
thank you Adam for this great q a
session do you have any final comments
for our audience
yes I do thank you yes just one one
comment really if if any of our webinar
attendees are interested in receiving
more information about the Genesis
system or the slides that sell sex
slides or would just like to chat with
one of our Byron cell experts about
their research and how it relates to
what we've just uh talked to and
presented please use your question box
and type in the word info
info and we'll get back in touch with
you for either providing more
information or conversation around your
applications
thank you again Adam for your time today
and your important research we also want
to thank lab Roots first and our sponsor
biorad Laboratories for underwriting
today's educational webcast
again before we go I do want to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions we had
several questions we did not have time
to answer so those questions and any
questions submitted during that
on-demand period they will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab Roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us and we hope you
have a great day bye-bye